my default settings factory settings
we're just you know pro-choice
Republicans are evil all they care about
is money
you you're the good you're the good guys
Democrats or we make a lot of
inappropriate jokes and I'm you know we
were joking on this week so I'm like
Maggie was say no who's gonna want to
sponsor this show because I said
something like I was joking about how
the Golden Globes went vegan and I was
like I just missed the good old days
right you know a man could be a man and
a woman who's in the kitchen I'm at you
Jesus you can't make even jokes like
that because someone will clip that and
then say see here is Bridget with her
internalized patriarchy unless you say
that everyone from the 1950s was a
racist bigoted homophobe you're
cancelled I yeah but is it should we
just pre cancel because comedy is I
think saying though you know I said
something that was really it's always
those off-the-cuff jokes you make that
are completely inappropriate that I
think I said something about cardi B and
we were filming and the dumpster fire
which and and I said you know she said
threatened to go to Nigeria and I said I
was like I have fun with Boko Haram and
go back and Sam who are in there filming
with me right my cousin Maggie who's my
producing partner in Samantha who's also
on the team they started dying laughing
because it's that's what's funny is
those things that are off-the-cuff and
if you say something like that now and
you aren't in a position like I'm in
which is I slightly immune to cancel
culture you will get cancelled or your
own risk of getting cancelled so I think
comedy has become a lot more afraid and
then you know the argument that people
say is like cancel culture isn't real is
that people like Ricky Gervais and Dave
Chappelle are making jokes well they're
millionaires yes they're multiband
they're powerful
so you're just you can't use people who
or even JK Rowling you can't use Bill
and multimillionaires as examples of
people who are who are canceled proof
because they're canceled proof just
because we're rich do you sense though
that people like us maybe a if Gervaise
and Chappell let's say are doing it at
like the Air Force level right that were
sort of more the foot soldiers in this
or something like or we're in the tanks
on the ground and we're offering cover
to the average person that is the foot
soldier in this that just wants to be
able to work a real job but still
occasionally say what they think without
being mobbed and where we are actually
offering them a little bit of cover yeah
yeah I think that people want people
feel confused and there is that sense of
terror that's but also hilarious and we
were talking about this as well and
Dunster fired just how it's you're
you're it's almost like a defense fumer
for me as a defense mechanism it is for
many people and that's why inappropriate
jokes are funny because you're like
hahaha
World War three right guys and then the
memes come out and the memes are
hilarious and so people are using humor
to try and make sense of a world that's
really crazy and then you have all these
people who are experts and I always say
no one knows anything I mean even
experts they might know things about
they might have things to contribute but
no one knows what's gonna happen so
anyone who's telling you like here's
what's gonna happen is really just
projecting their own biases and hopes
into the world but no one is like
Nostradamus we're not in it so I think
people just want to laugh to make sense
of it you mentioned your factory
settings yeah which I have credited you
with many names 99% sure I credited you
and I mentioned it in the book I
suddenly as I'm saying it I'm suddenly
afraid that I didn't but I'm but let it
be known that you were the first person
that came up with the phrase factory
settings that I had ever heard can you
just explain what factory settings are I
know we talked about it last night but I
think it's such a right way of sort of
looking at at why everything is so
screwed up or or sort of how you would
take everything down to first principles
to then
look at the world yeah factory-settings'
is really just the default that you were
kind of installed as a child for
instance I was raised in a very liberal
family
it was very East Coast we I didn't I was
thinking about the other day I'm like I
don't think I even met anyone who was
pro-life until I was better yeah maybe
yeah and I just was not exposed to I
didn't I I was in Minnesota but we lived
in the city so I was always very much
and and again I wasn't really you know
engaging in the debate club at school so
I didn't I had some conservatives in my
life but my default settings factory
settings we're just you know pro-choice
Republicans are evil all they care about
is money
you're the good you're the good guys
Democrats are poor yeah do you think so
do you think that's a personal thing or
that generally that we're not when I've
used the phrase maybe this is my own
take on it I've sort of said to people
that the factory settings that were all
given pretty much if you grow up in
America or you know in the last 40 years
let's say is that that is the narrative
so yes of course some people are brought
up say Christian conservative they're
brought up pro-life or whatever but
that's really a that's really an outlier
right to the main set of ideas that are
sort of accepted out of the gate which
are Democrats good Republicans bad
Democrats for poor people Republicans
for rich people Democrats you know all
of that kind of well it just depends on
where you grow up because I think
everyone's factory settings are
different and that and it depends on
your region so if I was raised them you
know somewhere in the South perhaps or
in Texas or in a different family than
perhaps I would have different factory
settings my very good friend is was
raised conservative and he was raised to
think all liberals are idiots
yeah but um and that they you
can't can't argue any of their own
points they they so he that he just
won't even really engage in a leftist
debate because he he thinks that that
was the way he was raised by his family
that was conservative but it was also
known that they were not the mainstream
point of view or right that set of ideas
wasn't writing coming down to you from
Hollywood and the media all the time
right and to kind of keep those ideas
somewhat on the down-low so even in
graduate school he had to he's had to
kind of pretend just fake go along with
a lot of the crazy stuff that he's seen
and just because he wants to kind of
swim through and get done and and be
done with it but so I think there that's
interesting too I don't know i I've been
it's been interesting hearing from as
many conservatives as I have in the past
couple years their own struggles at
colleges and how they're kind of these
you know they're outliers really in the
culture and I didn't I never knew that
because I was just like whatever let's
back up for a second though because that
is relative to all this for people that
that don't know you or didn't see our
first interview you're a former addict
yeah I think in a lot of ways seems to
set up sort of your view on all of this
that this isn't that the culture warfare
as important as it is right and this is
what we do every day and and I do
believe that this fight is the fight for
Western values and all of these things
like it is important but that you've
already lived through like your own
existential battle for existence right I
feel like that you know I grew up in a
kind of crazy household too so I think
there are a lot of people probably like
me who grew up in dysfunctional homes
where the culture as it's gotten
increasingly more crazy I'm like that
meme
you know dog drinking coffee like this
is fine while everything's on fire
because that was what I was used to so
the culture is finally reflecting I got
caught up to this functional home but I
think the existential crisis the first
time I had it was 19 you know let's be
clear I'm still an addict I was making
you a retiree yeah I know I know that's
still there I can do anything
addictively even if it's good for me and
I have a I do have like a crazy you know
I get fixated on things and obsessed
with them Twitter is a great example I
have a hard time people are always like
how do I get on Twitter what do I do
I don't know what to tell them because I
love Twitter I need to put myself away
yeah
so I but you take some breaks too I do
and I have a my I have a pretty healthy
relationship to social media for the
most part but I find it's about to get
healthier we're going to talk about yeah
my my I think what being in recovery has
done for me during all of this craziness
and I have I just celebrated six years
of sobriety in October it I can't
personally be an anger or resentment
because it puts my sobriety in danger so
I can't live with that stuff so I
quickly have to figure out how to come
into acceptance if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about comedy instead of the non-stop
yelling you get everywhere else check
out our comedy playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlists they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell